in shaping the way that we look and the
program and our relationship between
academic learning and experiential
learning through the voice of people
like ourselves and the history
discoveries in our program one of them
was the interviewing the oral history of
the arresting fellows at least one of
whom is here with us tonight who shall
read who we included took the oral
history up four years ago and history
has actually shaped the lives of a
number of students who are now
graduating from after that experience
Mary Marshall gave us Marie Schettino
and our mentor in rural history and two
years ago Marie was the one who taught
us how to create created projects
in New York City presenting them the
next year Mary Marshall Clark gave us
Sarah Jessica who now defected back to
the Center for history
not without changing our lives in the
program and many of our students still
go back to Sarah for mentorship and
summer projects of all these contacts we
have all been pining to hear
Rita Sharon talk I know she has spoken
to our colleagues in the three
professional office can the Center for
student advising and she's always a big
draw so it was an incredible pleasure
for me to be asked to co-sponsor this
event with with isert and with the
fungus Center for oral history and
without any further ado I am going to
introduce Marie who will then introduce
our main speaker
and she has received a foundation for
residency and research funding from the
NIH any age and several private
foundations
and
when I say the kind of
invite others to come think about this
we end up with nurses physical
therapists chaplains patients which you
know I think you know as soon as I say
that I kind of know Clark's with very
dense trees and
if only in the effort to forestall so
I'm going to read some of this because
and I warn you now
there was shelling
I have a few lines of that they're all
things that move
necessarily from my airplane window on
that part of the earth in beholding I
was chosen for a privilege I was
bestowed a rare prospect on the planet
on which we live I was the only one
looking at
the responsibility to fulfill the duties
in
it would be very very important and more
and more people came from farther and
farther than farther away you know so we
have Australians Japanese South Koreans
exactly
why is it too
as well as
so we kind of distilled some of these
emerging ways of looking so one way to
say is that narrative medicine provides
clinicians and this goes beyond doctors
and nurses and so the word clinicians is
the best I can do to include in that
clearing all who care for this area so
if you're a chaplain if you're a
receptionist in my clinic if you're the
lady who does the insurance evaluation
so narrative medicine provides
clinicians with the tools to hear what
ill persons say to receive their
challenging grueling part of council
itself to face the condition of knowing
it was exposes the cells and exactly the
same time that the self resists exposure
often whether the illness is the result
of trauma habits genes or chance the
person afflicted with the field or worse
is made to feel to blame medical
problems in particular parts of the body
related to sex excretion behaviors that
without the
in fact you're white nor brooms in which
one writes in invisible ink in these
remotes does the care proceed these are
the rules of care in the dark of
knowledge in the silence of truth our
patients find some way to tell us we
find some way to hear them and then we
seek ways to fulfill the duties incurred
by virtue of having her
to absorb our teaching methods include
training in these methods of imagination
expand invite the creators
what goes on donations fathers we enable
them to learn what's at stake and to
come to understand how this all of this
replaces the shame with honor
so I'm a general internist most of my
patients are old and sick and poor and
so they do not do well some suffers from
catastrophic massive strokes violence
all have a great deal to tell to me
they're interns and also to themselves
and I learned early on the dividend of
letting someone talk to me in the office
sometimes oftentimes
about the violence the unfairness the
needless we learned through our long
hard apprenticeships or when that
injured servicemen was that raped or
know when their childhood asthma when
that old man losing his mind says in
whatever way to use you can I have been
injured what is to be done we are the
ones to answer that call
and this is why I have to the call is
most frequently sounded in sectors of
health care because the body is the
thing that connects the human being to
the world and because the body is in
strict terms that which is violated in
all of these situations or disease or
trauma it falls to those who care for
the body to eat the call of the injured
self within and I say that in full mind
that physical injury is but one little
stratum of suffering and realize that
full well there's something a little
peculiar on the way you live today that
suffering comes to healthcare before it
goes to simply because
the suffering whatever you when you need
whatever that is some say is that with a
body like we express ourselves
we smell we fall head-over-heels in love
we eat with us we hit blind and these
bounties
in his latest novel called the
infinities John Banville anyway in this
novel the infinity john vento stage is a
scene on Mount Olympus where Zeus and
Estella gods
gaze down at the hapless mortals they
have created
Zeus envies our mortality this is a
world
this
it's not
and illness comes to us within or or as
we get to see at the very very beginning
something happens in your body
now it's commonly thought are commonly
said that stories of beginnings in those
events and but the stories we see in
healthcare are just not like that that
are more like storms at sea
I mean winds come waves power arriving
so you know maybe the meteorologists
will say the storm started here to keep
their end there those who live on that
Shore know the storm the bridge because
the shore changes by virtual
so how do you how do you leave you dead
child
and return to the vacant routines of
whatever you call your life
so we can accept there are clinical duty
include the duty to develop this sense
of story this sends what gives this
father mother underwent in the course of
this engines brain to chemotherapy and
radiation surgery
that those of us caring for that
charming and that money many and that
little sisters or basis today
not just the visible but the story
entire
that we have to develop the skills
necessary to understand what those
parents of that dying baby need from us
to comprehend the losses of the woman
after having been raped to face the
uncertain future with the middle-aged
man now speechless after a stroke only
with this sense of story will we be able
to contribute what say first was in
there now he's need either to get better
or to suffer the consequences of their
loss of health hemmond ends his account
of the death of his baby daughter Isabel
by realizing that quote her available
abstinence is now an organ in our bodies
function is continuous secretion of
it doesn't let us off the hook
so one has to prove that
unwellness is not being caused by
something in one of the organs and when
it's printed that it's not a malfunction
of one of the organs well then we can
think about what might cause suffering
DC and that always brings down the
course because if you come to me with a
headache and MRIs and hot-to-trot
and then they say your brain is fine all
the tests are negative right all the
tests are negative then you say go ahead
there's nothing wrong it doesn't help at
all you know it's all in your head
so so the person doesn't have an answer
to what is causing the suffering and now
that makes feel stupid because they
bothered you with a complaint that's not
real
so it's goofy it's backward and
eventually we'll get it better but
that's how we already so because of that
many of us start instead with another
opening some time ago I finally stopped
doing all the inventory questions
so we learned instead I usually say two
questions
and to absorb from the words she said
silence is where the where the posture
change what my body's immune response
now I found myself and to the extent
that I could not just look for the
in such a short breath so so this is one
example
now when I'm doing the physical exam
I'll always ask the questions like one
is you last PPV when you allergic to and
tell me about that it's far so so you
know we managed to do the business but
it's always in the grounds of how this
person made frame that which he or she
came into the office I saw last week in
the office of patient
for a long time but her daughter was
stalwart non standing unconditionally
committed to the characters after her
mother's death
the daughter asked me to become her
doctor which is a privilege together the
daughter have weathered a major
as we saw problems together we finally
underwent surgery I gently fingered the
well healing scar of the operation we
were loosely looked at one woman knowing
all did line beneath that scar the
mourning for her mother the fear that
something interloop develop in their own
manner our relief that the pathology did
not show in cancer centers we celebrated
wordlessly greatly her courage and
having been able to submit to the
surgery at all we appreciated
severe depression cannot come back in
the face of this physical assault but
that we do want to do they did after
examining the neck were in surgery
clicking tongue addition to her heart
and lungs I examined her belly I checked
her skin for any
I have been writing this about her and I
wanted to myself so I brought my
secretary delay on this short
description and she called me as soon as
she got it to say that she too felt
grateful for the work we had done
together and I read this and in the
course of doing
but this
dimension which is my hand on her belly
and that is said with as much reverence
as I can say so so the two of us then
clinician and nation are divided on the
grounds of her illness United in the
fundamental search for meaning and the
needs to navigate this very primordial I
mean the underneath the underneath the
basic state although although the
disease or the fear of it or the effort
to prevent it may be the pretext for
once United in the effort to face
mortality we are launched so I think
what it means is now in this culture
anyway
in this situation so doctors nurses
health care professionals instance
accounting is a heightened experience
through which by in current of duties to
register what I see to appreciate what I
see to recognize its uniqueness to be
summoned to look at what I am granted
the privilege as I recruit what I know
I summoned as well my sense of the
sublime I experienced the vastness of
this one woman's cosmos
the powerful incontrovertible
unassailable statement made by something
by being itself by coincidence qxr the
class of the radio station plays box
orchestral suite really number three
indeed the one that I heard on the
airplane I the Canadian once again I
left this suite flare through my
earphones elevating me to wordless
planes of pleasure by its beauty its
power its harmonies I move in concert
with the Suites rooms from brass and
percussion fanfares
to soulful sorrowful largo passages that
back to my childhood memories am i now
dead father listening to
this movement with such gratitude so we
are here with our heritage our paths our
connection to the living and the dead
with our adverting minds we seek the
meaning of my lives as we undergo their
pain and suffering not cancelling out
the joys but sculpting them into unique
monuments himself as we are born and
every time we revolved subside and swell
filled with the sustenance of others
moved into self by the mysteries of self
we behold and this goes on every day day
in day out by virtue of the care
the uncertainty you made the patient
they feel they know they come to the
doctor to be told something and forgive
us but there it is such precious little
devil and so
are usually not and patients know this
because now even though just as well as
I can and you know what happens if
you're going to office with internet
something or other and then either say
that stupid or they get me because
suddenly we don't have the engine right
but the point of making is we are not
separated because one group is on stir
and one dessert or all suffering
burdened by the uncertainty which is
hiding nonetheless nonetheless the
professional power is undeniable and
those of us who by virtue of having gone
to professional School
our festive
our position
we're venting to the petition that
sometimes were entreated to use as any
power tell me what to do
the longevity of the relationship itself
is bad they recently made the office I
work in this clinic paperless suddenly
there's no pavement because and my I was
away it's a little break from my
practice for six months to work on these
folks and I go back and they said well
it's paperless now and they say we got
the guy coming tomorrow you can shred
all your today and Thursday and go
through them and see what you okay
that I can show this is G what we did in
1984 when she came in that belly pain so
there's some kind of longitudinal
familial recognition
what patience patience sacrifice is the
feeling of being recognized and if I not
only recognize and the recognition then
Bonnie never know it can't be your call
button as we took that out of 1984
beyond that it's it's the unknown so
that's over
and we are old that we are both angry
when I keep Grand Rounds and there's a
bunch of internist at some Hospital and
they say Sharon who's got the time to do
that and at the beginning I said really
doesn't think we're time just use the
time differently and I see and initially
we get
do this and then go up and write a story
and that's the conversation quick
context
the conversation is home on earth it
says twelve months and we know the
answer to that right or whoever makes
health policy in this country so there's
many ways to you know open up these
questions
and and so that's part of what one has
to read is you know don't take 20
minutes all I need so so but you're
asking the deeper question
it's only the
required
their invasion exposures
then each of us each of us
boundaries
and if there's anything to be known
about a person who comes for any kind of
service
where those boundaries are and that's
not to be violent does that mean I mean
those those are the those are the things
we have to think about in these areas
that areas of very very tender so and
there's all different ways of filing you
want to talk about shame it means that
something's been finding some common
so that constitutes the shame and that's
why in this do you know who work by
Kwame Anthony
on the honor code and so not only is not
viable but using
and it's up to you to tell me what you
know
yes
from its it's highly
it is a reduction to have a chosen other
now many persons choose and their sister
daughter some and just comparing that to
having the creative tells us exactly
what the daughter is on your side the
daughter is there for you the PA is
there not treated the PA is there to let
the orthopedist see three times as many
shoulders as he could without
is there without
so I have learned how much 23 feeling
Hamptons because I'm a participant in
that encounter I can't see it
and so I occasionally witness who I have
trained to perceive and represent the
visiting account and I and they're not
there to learn
and
I've changed by virtue but I'm going to
win so and then when we give in to the
patient
well then it becomes just another angle
so that's different but still it's more
in my service than had the patient
brought Francisco